the Department of Justice announced
yesterday that the U.S Army's first ever
transgender officer has been indicted
for trying to provide confidential
health records to someone he believed to
be a Russian agent and today
we're just trying to make sense of the
shocking news
who could have possibly foreseen that a
severely mentally ill man might do
something unusual and disordered it just
doesn't add up
a man who thinks that he is a lady got
confused about which country he is
supposed to be serving it's a regular
man bites dog kind of story
that word service keeps coming back to
me because while now ever since the
Obama Administration
the U.S military has become a place of
entitlement for people with all sorts of
circumstances that make them less than
fit for the battlefield it was not
always that way in the way back olden
days of about a decade ago the U.S
military was an institution dedicated to
service
not to affirmative action
not to the affirmation of delusion
service
tough guys signing up to sacrifice to
protect the rest of us
now that Dynamic has flipped not just in
the military but throughout virtually
all of our institutions an inversion
that has already led to far greater
disorder than a man in a dress I'm
Michael Knowles is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
I just I'm just trying to make sense of
it it just doesn't make sense my
favorite comment yesterday from Snooki G
who says frankly I am less surprised
that lizzo was given this Priceless and
irreplaceable item to desicc right than
I am that she didn't purposefully break
it as a protest against slavery and
oppression
actually is a floutist
actually actually really enjoyed playing
the flute but for the libs who set this
whole thing up yeah it's true they hate
James Madison it's all a big political
stunt founding fathers bad racist
terrible evil America bad this is just
making a mockery of all of that which is
why you have this this lady jiggling
around with barely any clothes on making
a mockery of James Madison's flute but
they wouldn't destroy it necessarily at
least not at first because
in many ways these National symbols that
they desecrate
it actually those symbols and
institutions have more value to the libs
if they are kept around in some way so
the the institutions and the symbols
have more value to the libs if the libs
can just destroy them rip out their guts
invade them like Invasion of the Body
Snatchers and then kind of prance around
in them and this is this is true of
virtually all of the institutions the
church the libs go into the churches
they gut the churches they pull out all
the stuff that make the churches the
churches then they go in and turn them
into some kind of woke
machine with the facade of a church
that's more useful to the lips it's true
of our executive agencies it's true of
the universities it's true of the media
it's true it's true of everything and so
I don't think that the libs will destroy
it yet they're going to exploit these
symbols and use them for a little bit
longer to to communicate their messages
when you want to communicate your
message where are you going to go you
got to check out here your talk right
now head on over to puretalk.com enter
code Knowles the government is addicted
to spending that Reckless spending is
driving up the costs of everything it's
not fair but you don't have to be a
victim there are things that you can do
right now to lower your monthly expenses
and mitigate the impact of inflation
step one switch your cell phone service
to Pure Talk take a look at your cell
phone bill if you are with Verizon ATT
or T-Mobile
I know how much you're paying you're
paying way too much pure talk will give
you unlimited talk text and six gigs of
data for just thirty dollars a month
that could be a huge savings for you and
your family that's grocery money gas
money whatever pure talk it never raises
their rates by switching to Pure Talk
the average family of four is saving
over 75 dollars every month customers
are realizing that they simply do not
need as much data as they thought join
the hundreds of thousands who are making
the switch to pure talk today when you
switch to pure talk with my special
discount you will get 50 off your first
month go to puretalk.com choose your
plan and enter code Knowles for this
special offer that's puretalk.com enter
code Knowles Kim w l e s for 50 off your
first month
on the civilian side of things putting
the military aside for a second on the
civilian side of things
Virgin Airlines has just made a big
announcement they've got a big dress
code change for their stewardesses and
now stewards I guess uh also in the
airline because
well it's a little confusing I guess
because now the stewards can dress like
the stewardesses and the stewardesses
can dress like the stewards virgin
announces we've changed our uniform code
to give our crew pilot and ground teams
the option to choose which of our Iran
ironic iconic uniforms designed by
viviane Westwood best represents them
that was a Freudian slip because now the
uniforms are going to be ironic rather
than iconic because the men are going to
dress like ladies and vice versa
my first reaction when hearing this
announcement
do you remember
when the service industry was about
serving customers
do you remember that that was a long
time ago I I've worked in the service
industry before I've worked in
restaurants I've worked catering I've
worked at best food I've worked and call
me old-fashioned when I was coming up in
those jobs
the point was to give the customer what
the customer wanted the customer was
always right your job in the service
industry is to make the customer feel
more comfortable feel better
I do not want to see some husky deluded
man wearing a skirt on my flight I never
fly virgin anyway but if I were to fly
virgin I mean it's a completely failing
Airline this is probably some last gasp
desperate effort to save their stock but
if I did ever find myself on one of
those airplanes I would not want to see
some husky confused dude prancing around
pretending to be a chick I don't like
that as the customer now you might say
well well what about the stewardess or
Steward or I don't care my job is not to
accommodate them their job is to
accommodate me as the customer and then
when I'm working in the service industry
my job is to accommodate my customers
okay I remember I was working a catering
job many years ago
and the the manager who was running the
shop he said okay I remember guys what
is this all about what are we all doing
here what's the purpose of this job and
in my mind I thought I don't know to
make a little bit of money and then go
home but no that's that's the
consequence of it sure I guess that's
that's why we wake up and go to work to
some degree we got to feed ourselves put
a roof over our head but what is the
purpose of that industry the purpose of
that industry is to serve the customer
and we've totally inverted that now now
it's all about making
the the service people feel good about
themselves and it's true in the military
too we've the military which was all
about sacrifice and you sign up and you
put yourself in danger and you don't get
paid very much and you don't get good
food and you don't get to sleep very
well and it's just hard it's a really
hard job but you do that because you are
serving the public and now what do we
hear from the military well it's my it's
my right
as a transsexual gay lesbian this that
the other thing it's my right to serve
in combat no it's not your right
the military is not about your rights at
all you sign your rights away when you
join the military at least you're
supposed to it's supposed to be about
sacrificing other people but we can't
think that way anymore
our Cult of selfishness
which you saw led by the left
but it has not exactly been resisted by
the right either the right has embraced
its own version of The Cult of
selfishness greed is good money at all
costs you know Wolf of Wall Street kind
of iron Rand style right-wingedness in
America it's it's just the flip side of
that kind of selfishness the
individualism the incessant focus on my
rights and entitlements it's everyone in
America has kind of bought into this but
no one's benefiting from it it hasn't
led to a flourishing country
it's just led to a selfish country where
no one's serving anybody else and then
everybody's miserable
speaking of refusing to serve
an amazing story in the Washington post
about someone who works for the
Department of Child Services
and uh he I guess I guess it's a she but
she now identifies as a he and so the
Washington Post calls her he and the
wapo says he came out as trans then
Texas had him investigate the parents of
trans kids
and this this confused lady who dresses
like a man was very upset by this
because the Texas governor came out and
said look it's it is child abuse when
parents try to convince their little
sons that their daughters and daughters
that their sons and especially when they
take them to doctors to pump them full
of hormones and chop off their body
parts it's a child abuse and it might
not even be an intentional child abuse
but it is parents can abuse their kids
without knowing it or without
necessarily Desiring to but it can
happen and so we're not going to let
that happen in Texas anymore the voters
of Texas support this initiative but
what about this lady this very confused
lady this mentally ill lady who thinks
that she's a man says well I don't want
to
I don't want to execute on that order
so she she goes she goes on a couple of
these calls and she's crying and she's
saying this is wrong this is terrible
but I have to do it but I'm sorry you're
a wonderful family that's trying to
trans all your kids but I know I'm so
sorry and then finally she quits
finally that's the happy ending to the
story she should quit
she shouldn't be in this job in the
first place
she has no right to this job she has no
right to deny the orders of her boss
ultimately her boss the governor she has
no right to deny the desires of the
people of Texas who still have to some
degree at least have have the right to
self-government
so she resigned as well she should
that is good this is political power
we should
we should pressure to resign or fire
outright all of the bureaucrats in the
public sector and in the private sector
who don't want to carry out
who don't want to abide by the laws that
we pass as the political Community
that's a great thing that is political
power now you might say you might be a
little cautious about this and say well
gosh that sounds an awful lot like
cancel culture it does yes all cultures
Cancel as I've said for a long time all
cultures have standards and so the
question is are we going to wield
political power for bad ends like
trancing kids and abusing people and
denying the will of Voters in our sacred
democracy are we going to do that or are
we going to wield political power to
good ends like protecting kids and
saving little babies and having a good
country and protecting our country and
living in a flourishing Society what is
it are we gonna which are we gonna do
I'm for the latter call me crazy call me
a far-right radical extremist I think
that we should wield just political
power to improve things and protect good
things rather than to do the opposite
now you might think we're winning here
you might say this is good stuff
you get the strange people in the Child
Services Department in in Texas to
resign if they don't want to stop
trancing the kids okay that's good
that's but but don't delude yourself we
are losing on the issue of
transgenderism okay
transgenderism is progressing
a pace we're getting lots of good Clips
out of it who can forget there was that
wonderful clip of Marcia Blackburn
asking katanji the the katanji this is
the problem with women who use three
names I don't know if it's katanji
Jackson Brown or katanji brown Jackson I
think it's katanji brown Jackson anyway
uh uh side point when Marcia Blackburn
is grilling her and says what is a woman
and she says what is I don't know what a
woman is I'm not a biologist
that's preposterous obviously Matt's
movie a hilarious expose of this
insanity and it shows I think I think
those clips and those movies and those
arguments are really effective at
showing people how crazy the transgender
argument is but if you if you just look
at where the state of the country is on
the protection of sexual identity and
and gender expression on the on the
protection in the civil rights laws by
the way on the protection of transgender
bathrooms on the production of
transgender Sports we're still losing on
that issue
Dr bavik Kumar
who is a Planned Parenthood Affiliated
doctor
shows up to the Capitol to be grilled by
members of Congress he is grilled by
representative Andrew Clyde who is a
republican from Georgia
representative Clyde asks a really basic
question Dr Kumar gives a Preposterous
answer
let's just keep it real simple just two
yes or no questions and this is for um
Dr Kumar
Dr Kumar can biological men become
pregnant and give birth
so men can have pregnancies especially
trans men
I love how he says men can have
pregnancies
especially trans men
even if you're willing to go with the
libs on the whole there is such a thing
as trans men and trans women and that's
a real ontological category
what other group of men can get pregnant
and give birth if you
I get it's it's
silly to say it but I get I get the the
libs at least would argue women and
trans men can get pregnant and give
birth
but what's with the especially what is
this third group is there a third one or
a fourth one who knows it's it's yes
it's absurd that Planned Parenthood guy
looks like a total weirdo and a dope and
we're all laughing at him and we're all
mocking him but then you got to ask
yourself okay if we're all having such
fun on this issue and it's such a winner
with the public and everyone knows that
men aren't really women deep down
then why are we still losing legally and
politically
why is why is transgenderism
exploding especially among young people
transgender and gender non-conforming
identity why is this ideology exploding
throughout the universities throughout
the workplace virtually every company in
America has some Dei division that is
protecting the rights of transgender
individuals we're totally losing on the
issue why is that
well I think in part it's because the
conservatives are not putting up a tough
enough fight yes we get our clips and we
laugh and we Giggle and they can't tell
us that that men can't give birth
but just ask yourself this and you if
you're listening to this show you you
probably look pretty clear-eyed at this
issue okay you're you are not a squish
you are probably not a lib you're
probably looking pretty
do you ever call Bruce Jenner Caitlyn
Jenner
do you ever refer to a man who
identifies as a woman as she
it publicly or privately
do you ever do you do you say hey look I
we shouldn't trans the kids but adults
you know if an adult wants to cut off
his body part that's no business of mine
and if an adult wants to put on a dress
and call himself Sally why that's his
right that's no business of mine because
if you say that I'm not attacking you
I'm not criticizing you I'm just
pointing out if you say that
then you are
you are accepting transgenderism
if you say that then you are implicitly
agreeing with the Planned Parenthood
doctor that some men can get pregnant
and have children
because you're saying
you're saying that Bruce Jenner really
is a woman if you call him Caitlin
Caitlyn's a girl's name it's not a boy's
name
well you can you can legally change your
name to whatever you want yeah you can
but it doesn't change the fact that
Caitlyn is a girl's name and so if
you're calling the guy by a girl's name
and especially if you're calling him her
you are you are accepting the premise
that some men can get pregnant and give
birth and some women can really be men
you're accepting it if you say that men
can get the or adult adults rather can
get the gender affirming surgery then
you are accepting the premise that some
men can get pregnant you're not saying
it in
exactly the same crazy kind of terms as
that weirdo from Planned Parenthood but
you're saying the same thing and I I
fear
that
in this effort to just have a
conciliatory middle ground and okay well
just don't do it to the kids okay just
don't do it to the eight-year-olds okay
just don't do it to the five-year-olds
okay just we keep losing losing more and
more ground if we're not willing to be
hardcore on this issue and just say no
it's all insane transgender surgery
obviously should be banned for everybody
no man has the right to call himself
Caitlyn we will never refer to him as
her and bathrooms are going to remain
single sex in virtually every case
unless it's a small shop and there's
only one bathroom to begin with unless
we're willing to go all the way on it
we're going to lose the issue and we'll
get fun Clips along the way and we'll
Giggle and we'll say look at these crazy
leftist snowflakes and then they're
going to keep winning politically do you
remember five or six years ago we used
to say all these crazy snowflakes on the
campuses just wait until they get to the
real world then those crazy silly
triggered snowflakes then they'll learn
and then what happened the silly crazy
snowflakes got to the real world and
just completely changed the world and
and now we're living in their world
I'm only laughing because I either laugh
or cry okay so yeah we should laugh at
it we should make fun of it we should
point out the absurdities but we got to
stand firm politically if we're not
willing to exercise the political power
we're going to be laughing all the way
to the gulags
speaking of Republicans losing
gosh we can do a week of shows on that
Mitt Romney
Mitt Romney former GOP Presidential
nominee unbelievably Mitt Romney
is refusing to support a republican
that's not a big story
there have been plenty of times when
Romney refuses to support Republicans
but in this case
Romney is refusing to support
his fellow Utah senator his fellow
Republican Utah Senator Mike Lee
Mike Lee
a conservative
a as mainstream a guy as there is as
good upstanding a sort of guy as there
is I I don't know Mike Lee very well but
I met him on a number of occasions and
chatted with him and he's just he's a
great guy
nothing really to object to in Mike Lee
mitt ROM and Mitt Romney and Mike Lee
both have the same religion even
same place same religion he refuses to
support it
why
because Mike Lee is getting a challenge
from that silly never Trump CIA
operative who tried to run against
Donald Trump in 2016 Evan McMullen
and Evan McMullen has no shot whatsoever
but he could be a sort of spoiler he
could take away support from Mike Lee he
could throw a a clear Republican seat
into question he could deny Republicans
the Senate majority this is going to be
a razor thin election in the Senate
probably
and ROM so Romney is willing to give up
Republican control of the Senate
for what I don't know because he says
that he's friends with both guys he says
I'm friends with Lee I'm friends with
McMullen so I'm not going to endorse
either according to people close to Mitt
Romney
according to the Washington Post
why would he do this
because
Mitt Romney doesn't care about who has
control of the Senate because Mitt
Romney probably wants to lose
he probably sort of wants to lose I
think a lot of these guys a lot of these
loser Republicans
I think they often want to lose because
it's a lot easier to be in the loser
position because then you don't have any
accountability you don't have any moral
risk I remember this during the Trump
fights of 2016. a lot of the people
there were plenty of reasons to be
skeptical of trump in 2016 I'm not I'm
not downplaying that
but when he became the nominee
a lot of people didn't want to vote for
him because they didn't want to Bear
responsibility for him because there was
risk we don't know we've never seen this
guy hold office before and so I don't
want to put my name on this because if
if we win and then he does stuff I might
feel responsible for that but if I sit
it out and allow Hillary Clinton to win
I will also be responsible for that but
I can at least have some deniability
that I'm responsible for Hillary and
then she's going to do all sorts of
terrible stuff and she's going to kill
the babies and trans the kids and
destroy the country and open the borders
but at least I won't have any moral
responsibility
I think a lot of these guys
kind of like losing they kind of like
losing because it's just easier and they
can keep raising money and they can keep
going on TV and they can keep pretending
to fight and they can keep pretending
that they're morally pristine but
they're not they're not getting anything
done
they're just cowards with a lack of
vision
speaking of Republicans by the way huge
really really big news report out on
Republicans this is from the hill
Republicans are pouncing again
this happens every so often the
Republicans I don't know they get it's
like maybe they have restless leg
syndrome or something but they just
their muscles stiffen up and they just
they pounce they pounce all the time
well now the Republicans are pouncing on
ailing markets to criticize Joe Biden
that's the news story from the hill
do you see the news story is not that
the markets are collapsing the the story
is not that the Biden economy is a
disaster
no no the story is that
seeing all of those things
the Republicans they sort of crouched
down and they are really loaded and then
they just
they just they pounce that's the story
Republicans pounds is
I don't need to tell you this you've
seen it for years Republicans pounce is
a leftist tactic
to turn attention away from the actual
news story which is a liberal Scandal or
failure
two Republicans pointing it out to the
conservative coverage of that story
whenever Republicans are pouncing you
can note man the Democrats are in
trouble later today you've got to come
hang out with me at 11 A.M Central for
all access live I will be answering all
of your questions tune in dailywire.com
discuss bring your questions we'll see
you there I'm going to be speaking to a
segment of my audience I've never
directly addressed before that would be
the Frat guys sup Bros what's going on
what's going on fellas
we are both unfortunately
poor and unfairly portrayed by the media
we're both among the men most hated by
woke razor companies and leftist
ideology which is very very sad when you
consider that fraternities raise
millions of dollars every year for
charity one Virginia Tech fraternity
alone raised 255 000 for Saint Jude's
Children's Hospital last year so with
that influence and Moxie in mind I
thought that I would share an idea you
know Jeremy's uh razors contest to win
the car the one where you can win
Jeremy's McLaren well we get that you
don't want to shuffle everyone around in
a two-seater sports car which is why if
you win you can take the quarter million
dollar cash prize instead I am sure that
your imagination will suffice to paint a
picture of all the fun and Goodwill that
a quarter million dollars will enable
for you and your friends listen most of
the top players in the contest still
have not hit the 210 referral Mark so
there is plenty of opportunity for you
to jump into the race and take it all
just go to jeremy'sraisers.com play to
get your referral link come November 1st
2022 we will see which of you is the
most woke free Fraternity in America
peace out fellas terms and conditions
apply
those Republicans are totally totally
pouncing that's what they do they pounce
what are we pouncing on while we're
pouncing on the fact that the economy is
even worse than
you thought it was the US economy was
weaker in the first half of the year
than previously thought according to the
Commerce Department well how's that we
know that in the first half of the year
the economy had two consecutive quarters
of negative GDP growth
that is a recession but the Biden
Administration didn't want to admit that
that's a recession so what did they do
the Biden Administration said no no this
is a a unique case we're changing the
definition of a recession because
actually uh you see the uh other
economic indicators were such that they
actually override the two consecutive
quarters of negative GDP growth and what
were those economic indicators
those economic indicators were the gross
domestic income which had been reported
as growing at 1.8 percent in the first
quarter and it was the low unemployment
rate and it was all these other things
so it actually overrides the negative
economic indicators well
yesterday the Commerce Department uh
revised those estimates of GDP and GDI
turns out gross domestic income did not
grow at 1.8 percent it grew at just 0.8
percent as an annual rate uh second
quarter GDI growth was just 0.1 percent
okay so it was just it was a total
collapse there's no way to argue
at this point that we are not in a
recession
there is no way to argue it
are you going to hear this from The
Establishment media no of course not all
you are going to hear from The
Establishment media is that the
Republicans are bouncing
so it makes it
I guess it just keeps coming back to
this this point that I I hope everyone
has learned during covid I certainly did
whatever you are seeing from the lips
you have to assume that what they're
promising you about their successes is
not true I think you have to assume not
only is it the worst possible option
that they're presenting but the things
actually are much worse even than they
are percepting so I think about this
with covid where they say oh the the
coveted vaccine it's totally safe it's
totally effective it you can't question
that at all and so
in the olden days I'd say maybe they're
exaggerating okay maybe it's not totally
safe maybe it's not totally effective
now though I just have to assume the
thing is not effective
at all at doing what they say will do
which is in the case of covid vaccines
preventing infection and transmission
and it's it's really not all that safe
at least by the perfect standard that
they were suggesting remember they said
it doesn't cause heart problems it
doesn't cause blood clots it doesn't
cause menstrual changes in women that's
completely insane it causes all those
things
in more cases than they would have let
on
much much worse than is being admitted
speaking of damaging things
speaking of damaging things
did you hear this story about the
nordstream 2 Pipeline and the north
stream one pipeline actually
so
this is the secret story of the Ukraine
Russia War
IA has a pipeline to Europe two
pipelines Nordstrom one Nordstrom two
those pipelines allow Russia to send gas
directly to Europe bypassing all sorts
of problems that they have by allowing
them giving them the opportunity to go
into Ukraine and it's a it's a really a
war
that's largely about energy leverage
okay
so a couple of days ago we find out that
the Nordstrom pipelines become damaged
who damaged the pipelines was it Russia
that seems unlikely was it Ukraine that
seems unlikely why was it not Russia
because Russia has no reason to do it
really
why would it not be Ukraine Ukraine does
have reason to do it but they probably
don't have the means to do it
was it Germany Germany definitely you
know Europe doesn't want to damage those
pipelines Europe's going to freeze to
death over the winter if they don't get
the energy back online
so who was it
the only actor in the world that I can
see that has means and motivation
would seem to be the power that is
funding the Ukrainian resistance in the
world would seem to be the United States
okay now you might say well that's good
that's good blow up that pipeline as the
state department and the president both
said they would do for the months
leading up to this moment
okay you might say good blow up that
pipeline
whether the United States did it
directly or indirectly or didn't do it
at all
it is hard to deny right now that the
United States
is in a proxy war with Russia a war that
we never declared
a war that we don't even really want to
admit to
and a war that seems to be escalated
now you've got Vladimir Putin annexing
whole parts of
Ukraine with all these sorts of
referenda Elections okay
it seemed it's this war we were told was
going to be over within two weeks now
it's escalating escalating escalating
world wars have started for Less
world wars have started for a lot less
and especially when you think of the the
Western view of this war the Western
view of this war has been really
straightforward Russia has no right to
invade a sovereign country okay very
easy enough Putin's a bad man okay sure
Putin's a bad man
but if you just write off your opponent
as a Madman as a crazy person it's not
going to help you fix any sort of
problems Putin's argument was that the
West had been expanding NATO Too Far
East and the West had been meddling in
Ukraine and the West had supported a
coup d'etat to get rid of the formerly
pro-russian leader of Ukraine and they
were threatening to have Ukraine join
NATO and threatening to Ukraine join the
EU and that this was an unacceptable
security risk for Russia
whether that's true or not I'm not
saying you got to agree with Putin's
argument or even think it's a sincere
argument whether that's true that's
that's what Russia was saying about the
situation
an America then wielding its power to
move its sphere of influence further
east what do we do right now
both sides seem to be very very dug in
both sides are now openly talking about
a nuclear war
there was a great article
like Christopher Caldwell in the
Claremont Review of Books
I said why are we in Ukraine what do we
want to get out of Ukraine what are the
stakes here what are we willing to pay
for it
world wars have started for a lot less
than this
world wars have started because Serbian
nationalists shoot random archdukes on
the streets okay
we are see yes the U.S is wielding power
we like it when the U.S yields power but
think about the way that we've wielded
power here we've we've wielded the the
financial system of the world
against Russia to try to destroy
Russia's economy to try to destroy the
ruble it hasn't had that effect if
anything all it's done is push Russia
closer to China and India
because they sort of have to because
they can't really do business in dollars
anymore
our policies which you might say yeah
America's strong if we're punishing
Putin well what what is the effect of
that policy but it's been to weaken the
United States as credibility as the
holder of the global Reserve currency
which is what gives us our Imperial
power around the world
so I'm not even saying the the
motivations here could be wrong with the
war but
the the war at America's role in the war
has not had the effect that we thought
that it would in many of the most
important cases the people carrying this
out are some of the least competent
people on planet Earth
okay
do we really trust these guys
to continue to manage the situation that
they've bungled from the beginning as we
get
closer and closer and closer to a
seriously hot escalated war with a
nuclear former superpower I don't think
I trust these guys I don't think I trust
the guys who think that men are secretly
women and who bungled our economy and
bungle our immigration bundle everything
I I don't know I would I would urge a
lot more caution okay our mailbag is
sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com select a plan and enter
promo code nulls to get 50 off your
first month it's taken away with the
voicemail back
hey Michael I've been a long time
listener first time asking a question uh
just like so many other families and
friends after Trump got elected I had a
falling out with my sister-in-law she is
on the left in a third wave feminist
type after a few years of barely talking
we had a big fight on Thanksgiving last
year we have since had a long
conversation with my brother and her and
we are at least talking again I know she
is against all my politics and but my
eldest nephew has a flat out said he
doesn't agree with her politically I
understand these are not my kids but I
feel obligated to lead them away from
her type of politics and
I want to be able to influence him in a
good way while also staying on decent
terms with my sister-in-law how can I
tread this line any help is appreciated
thank you Nostradamus
it's a tough line to tread because it's
not your kids that we're talking about
over here
I am always of the opinion
that we should
preserve our families at almost all
costs okay and yes it's very frustrating
when you see your siblings and your
cousins and whoever uh who are
uh you know raising their kids in all
these crazy sorts of ways and raising
them to be big Libs and it'll probably
hurt their lives in the long run yes
that's very very frustrating
uh but
they're not your kids I think you just
gotta say look different strokes for
different folks that's oh you and you
can even joke about it oh you crazy Libs
oh you oh there you go okay well
whatever pass the turkey please
yes I know it's frustrating it's sad to
see but
I think we have to cultivate a spirit of
resignation here next question
hi Michael my name is Isaac my question
to you is another dating life question
I'm 21 in college and I met a young
woman at the beginning of the school
year and we slowly grew into friends
she's a Christian too so I thought she
was a good fit if I got to know her two
weeks into the school year I told her
that I liked her and asked her out
unfortunately she told me she wasn't
ready for a relationship at the moment
but would still like to get to know me
as a friend I was devastated and it
really hurts a lot when I heard that I'm
still trying to figure out what to make
of what she said
is she done with me in terms of my
chances of dating her or is the door
still open if it is open what would you
suggest I do next should I wait and work
to improve on myself either physically
or spiritually
or should I continue to try to warm up
to her love the show
thank you so much great question I'll
give you some hard answers uh she does
not want to date you and she was just
being nice
uh when she said oh I don't know if I'm
ready for a relationship but let's be
friends
she was just being nice
so
that doesn't mean that you will never
end up dating her you very well might
end up dating her but I don't think
you're going to succeed in that by
continuing to push and show interest and
say Hey you know you sure you don't want
to get a cup of coffee now hey I don't
think that's going to work I think you
should try dating other people first and
then get her jealous and then maybe you
can date her a little bit later or maybe
the person that you start dating you
actually find you really like that
person and you end up dating her because
there's lots of fish in the sea that's
what I would do
okay I wouldn't
there is something to the social proof
of
if you're going out on dates I'm not
saying use other people just to get this
girl but I'm saying just accept the
reality that she doesn't want to date
you right now okay got to move on other
fish in the sea you always start dating
this girl a a an effect of that will be
that all of the other girls will start
looking at you with greater interest why
is that it's probably because this is a
fallen world and the imagination of
man's heart is evil from the very
beginning but that's just how it happens
when when people are dating other people
it sends a sort of social message that
oh this person must be desirable maybe I
should desire that person more so that's
what I would do I would not hang on in
the vain hope that just you know asking
her out in a different way will convince
her
I don't think it will I think you gotta
date somebody else next question
hey Michael long time listener been
listening for Years love your show uh so
my question for you is regarding the
national divorce
um I don't understand how you think that
the United States with its Myriad of
different culture groups can co-exist
under one state I just don't see it with
the differences between the various uh
Nations that are in this state and I I
don't see uh that it would be at all
beneficial to try and continue to force
any of these groups to live together and
it may be messy it may not the the
resulting uh separation but I think
that's the only way for long-term peace
and prosperity so how do you see these
groups coming together and living under
a single political entity
good question
I guess I'd flip the question back on
you you're saying there are different
nations within the putative nation of
the United States
and so it's crazy to suggest we all live
Under One Roof so we got to split up
what do you mean by Nations do you mean
all the different races and ethnicities
that's true that's true it's pretty
weird how many we've got Under One Roof
in a nation rather than we don't call
ourselves an Empire there have been
empires in history that have lots of
different ethnic groups and racial
groups but very few Nations nation
states that would say that
okay so how are we all supposed to live
together
how are we supposed to split up
you've got how many how many races and
ethnicities do you have in America all
of them like all of them on Earth
all living in all different cities and
states together so how are you you're
not going to split people up based on
race or ethnicity even if you wanted to
religion
okay religions is a little bit more of a
set Enclave but not really okay sure the
Mormons can break off in Utah
about the rest of us that's not gonna
how are you going to divide the country
that way
uh the libs and the conservatives again
we got a ton of purple States got a ton
of conservatives in the blue States a
lot of Libs in the red States
how are you going to divide that up
I oppose the national divorce because I
oppose divorce entirely because I just
think it's bad and disordered and it's
it's there's no end to it
there is no end when you start talk of
the national divorce we're all going to
end up we're gonna have 330 million
different nations on one
slab of a continent it's just not it I
just don't see you're asking me how I
think we can continue to live together I
don't we'll just keep on keeping on how
what we're all so different right I
guess we should use the force of culture
and politics to make us all a little bit
more united and United in a good way
with our eyes toward good to immutable
things that's what I would do and I want
to use culture and politics to do that
simple simple enough answer will it
happen I don't know but it's simple
enough
what about what's your answer for the
national divorce how are we supposed to
do that
I don't I've never heard in any way a
compelling argument for how the United
States is supposed to break up at all
forget about peacefully I've certainly
never heard any argument for how we
break up peacefully
but how do you break up
at all I just don't see it next question
Hello Love Guru and austere religious
scholar Michael knows my name is Vincent
love the show anyways I have a
hypothetical proposal that I think
should go into law a band of adultery
now there are some biblical passages
that uh could be argued about for what
constitutes adultery but if we were at
the very least in law to define adultery
as currently married person having
sexual intercourse of someone other than
their current spouse how well do you
think something like this could look in
Congress I think even the perverted left
is depraved to the point of supporting
adultery as well but uh how willing do
you think those in Congress would be
able to accept a proposal like abandoned
adultery thanks
Congress I don't know but at the state
and local level
that that seems like a no-brainer to me
I mean adultery
is illegal at the very least it's a
breach of contract and we've had plenty
of laws against adultery in American
history so yeah that for sure for sure
we should ban adultery if not at the
federal level at least at the state
level yeah I think I think conservatives
might might be open to that a lot of
conservatives have fallen into the kind
of libertarian squishy traps
for uh for many years but I think we've
come out of that I mean this is what I
write about my book speechless which was
trying to push the conservatives out of
that and I think largely it worked and
other people are advocating a more
robust
courageous morally clear form of
politics anyway so yeah totally that one
that's like a no-brainer okay
let's get to some regular mailbag
questions from Elaine
no I'm sorry not Elaine Ephraim very
different names Ephraim says hey Michael
I want to get your take about a certain
aspect of marriage do you believe you
should wait to marry someone you are
absolutely infatuated with like in the
movies or do you think that expectation
is unrealistic and will keep you single
I'm an orthodox Jew and my parents are
trying to set me up via a shidook speed
dating with arranged matches so that I
can start a family soon that's the way
they met and married in under two months
and they claim they grew to love each
other over time I want to meet a girl I
truly love before I marry though so I'm
torn thanks
good question
I married the love of my life I married
a girl that I just fell head over heels
in love with when I was like 11 or 12.
okay so I and that gives me great
comfort
and we split for college and I dated
other girls and I I wake up some nights
in a cold sweat thinking about the
horror of had I married someone other
than my wife
I'm I mean that without a hint of
hyperbole it is one of the great
constellations of my life that I know I
married this gal that I just absolutely
adore
and you you won't have that sort of
certainty
if you do the kind of speed dating
arranged marriage type thing now that
said
there's a pitfall to the you know just
Mary for your own romantic desires and
love and journey kind of thing which is
you could be 35 years old 40 years old
or older and and not get married and say
oh there's always someone better around
the corner oh I just haven't met the
person yet oh swipe right swipe right
and so your family and your community
especially in your religious community
they will know they will have a great
deal of wisdom on how to uh get married
and have a good family and what's best
for you so you don't want to disregard
that either I just think as I often say
I don't think it's a cop-out I think
it's actually the truest answer here you
need to use your Prudence okay and so
for me I would actually try to seek a
sort of Middle Ground here which is
instead of just walk outside throw a
stick pick the closest person on the
street and say okay you're my wife now
I would date yourself and kind of you
know take a little bit of time try to
get to know people maybe meet some girl
at wherever social situation you're in
but also get the input of your family
also take their advice seriously I would
try to do both of those things and I
think that'll give you I could give you
the best of both worlds next question
next question is from Pete hey Michael
I've been a DW plus member for almost a
year now and never miss your show even
if I have to listen to two or three in a
day I always catch up my man I have a
question for you other than cigars and
Libations great choices by the way what
do you do to relax and re-center I'm
guessing play with the kids is at the
top of that list but that's a given what
was just wondering keep doing what you
do
let's hold all the squishers accountable
great point I don't play with my kids to
relax I don't find that relaxing I find
it very fun and Sublime and wonderful
and I adore it but it's exhausting that
doesn't relax me at all yes I smoke
cigars I'll have a drink or two at night
I'll read a book that's that does relax
and re-center mean it's very very
important even if it means I get less
sleep I really try to do that
but I played music I love that and I'm
I'm not this is not false modesty I'm
not like particularly good at musical
instruments but I play a lot of them in
a very mediocre to poor way and I just
love it I love strumming my ukulele or
my guitar my banjo or my sitar or my
piano pluck it around you know I just
really love that I took up painting and
I I'm a very bad painter but I really
that especially can re-center you
because it just uses different parts of
your brain and
it lets you see the world in a different
way Winston Churchill write a whole
essay about this painting is pastime
where he said look if you're reading
this essay to get into painting you're
already too old and you're never going
to be a good painter so forget about
that just paint for sort of the joy of
of painting not as your career or your
profession but just as a Pastime and a
hobby that I find to be really really
great
is you want you want to be able to use a
different part of your brain uh to kind
of turn off the other part you're never
going to just turn your brain off
entirely it's always moving so you've
got to just use different parts of it
you know the rest of the show is
continuing now you do not want to miss
it because I'm about to be electrocuted
by David Cohn if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us we'll see you over there
[Music]
foreign